enfin au total c'est quand même vendu 55
millions d'albums
ouais c'est beaucoup voilà 54 millions
de sacs non non pas de quoi ça tient
elle a alors on connaît effectivement
moins bien vos activités de compositeur
et de paroliers et on va écouter
quelques chansons dont vous avez fait
les paroles je me dis
m
depuis
le promu
m
l'homme
pour parler
pas très joli jeu de
au palais
bon voilà bien aussi des choses pour le
normand pour françoise hardy etc
il ya une anecdote extraordinaire je
pense avec votre père un jour ils
ouvrent les fenêtres sur sunset
boulevard et avaient en face d'eux c'est
peut-être une affiche pour equinox
c'est vrai une belle revanche même si
c'est pas vous qui avez décidé de mettre
sérieusement ça se passe comment les
enquêtes là parce que ses candidats
merci
puis les enfants ont versé beaucoup